foreign
to believe that our behavior is
predetermined while also that we have
personal responsibility as mazimo was
talking about so
um perhaps I can go to you first because
you were making a sort of argument for
both weren't you you were saying yes and
it sort of depends on again how we're
defining terms so if you take this far
yeah so so as you just heard we have
specific areas of the of our brain that
are in fact in charge of decision making
or at least they're involved heavily in
decision making in a sense our brains
are sophisticated decision-making
machines
biological machines for sure complex uh
for sure but they are nevertheless
that's what they're for um that that's a
big part of what they do so in that is
the part of the web or causing effect
that I was mentioning a minute ago that
is internal to us and because my
particular Machinery is different from
yours or from yours and so on and so
forth than in a very important sense
those are my choices and not those of
somebody else
at the same time I worry a little bit
when we when we talk about
responsibility as opposed to let's say
ownership right so I have no problem
owning my own decisions meaning that I
can say those are my decisions when I
talk about responsibility but obviously
we're talking we're we're referring to
moral responsibility then the issue gets
a little bit more complicated for one
thing I think that moral responsibility
is not a particularly useful construct
because it's often used to just blame
people and punish people and do all
sorts of things things that are not very
constructive what we should be doing
when people make mistakes when people
make the wrong decision is to try to fix
what was wrong with that decision and to
try if possible even to fix the
Machinery that made that decision in
other words to rehabilitate people as
opposed to just put them out put them
away in jail for 30 years and and and
and lock the the thing and throw the key
out so it's more constructive I think to
not think in terms of moral
responsibility as much in terms of
flawed or or non-flawed decision making
more or less flawed decision making
I don't want to push the analogy too
much but if you have a complex machine
that makes decisions for of a certain
kind let's say a computer you don't
really blame the computer morally when
it makes a mistake you try to fix it you
open it up and you figure out okay what
is it exactly it's going on now we are a
lot more complicated than computers but
we're still biological machines so when
we make decisions now you mentioned a
minute ago for instance if there are
uh brain anomalies for instance or
genetic anomalies that uh lead certain
people to behave in ways that are
clearly out of the norm well that means
we just have identified a particular
cause and we can either fix that cause
or take that cause into account when we
make decisions about what to do or what
not to do
can I bring Sarah in on you were
mentioning that there are dedicated
areas of the brain that guide us because
you just fill in a little more about how
that operates in your research so the
there is this Dynamic relationship
between sort of Limbic circuitry and
emotional LED architecture in the brain
and there are inhibitory regions from
the prefrontal cortex which help control
those impulses and those inhibitions and
people may differ in those fundamental
drives bursts of anger may be higher in
some people but there is also these
regulatory areas which people can
exercise control and in the vast
majority of cases then that's why people
need to be accountable for for their
actions and I do agree with what you say
about
um the role of
society and of course there are
exceptions like psychosis but I disagree
with your pinpointing genetics okay
um because
genetics I mean there's something like
Huntington's disease which we know can
be derived from a single genetic
abnormality but the vast majority of
cases if it was a simple
um mapping of genetics to behavior we
would have cured many diseases oh yeah
yeah and so yeah no sorry I completely
agree yeah no I started I did not mean
to imply that there is any simple
mapping between genetics and and
behaviors there absolutely Isn't So
except for those very occasional cases
that you're you're talking about but
that said our genetic Machinery meaning
our our full genetic complement
obviously does make uh does account for
a lot of the causal web of what it means
to be you or me or somebody else yeah uh
you know we developing in a certain way
from growing up from from when we're
born on because in part of that genetic
machinery and how it interacts with the
environment in complex ways all I wanted
to say was that there are causes but
that doesn't mean that those causes are
easy to pinpoint or or or it's even
worth trying to pinpoint them yeah
and again why this is so fun for me it's
just a detail it's the art my argument
just goes as before I mean it doesn't
matter how you came to be how how you
are but it's not ultimately up to you
how you came to be but I mean what I
mean I of course think now that we we
need a fairly robust notion of personal
responsibility to run a society right as
obvious as a pragmatic the question is
to both of you really is whether you
think that
punishment I mean you tried to sign that
but you you can't sideline it that much
whether you think that punishment you
know as it were handed down by a court
is ever truly just or fair or is it just
pragmatically required or it's a good
question
so that you you know you've brilliantly
signaled this into the next area oh just
before we do that though I want to ask
you one question oh are we going to
retain that excellent question okay um
just one question about such because you
mentioned satra yes and I mean I guess
as you were saying you know he has that
notion that you make a pact with your
future self and that's fundamental to
being human is to say I will and then
you can make this decision I mean how
what our discussion relate to this sort
of satrian idea yeah well the the starch
was good at stories and his story is
set in the second world war and the
question is should I stay behind to care
for my very sick mother or should I go
off and join the resistance and his
point was really he says you're
condemned to Freedom that is you're not
free not to choose that's the sense in
which you're content with you have to
choose
um that's that's all I had in mind there
yeah um yeah okay well let's pose your
question then I think we'll do it should
we do that so the next one I mean I
sympathize very much with what Massimo
said at the beginning about you know
you're saying I don't think this notion
of ultimate moral responsibility is very
valuable but I mean it does look any
anyone who believes in any story about
heaven and hell is committed to
something like that sure and that's why
that is just out yeah that is I mean I I
agree I agree so you asked uh you know
and and what circumstances punishment is
is a good idea I don't think I need any
circumstances it is a good idea yes well
this is tremendously counterintuitive
yes what happens now I bet somebody's
already thought of it someone says what
about Hitler right of course and um okay
so since you brought it up too I mean
with this so with this question of
punishment do we have to prove
scientifically that the person has a
gene for example that accounts for the
crime I think it's irrelevant or are you
saying the whole structure the whole
structure yeah so suppose one guy is
brought up in a broken home and poverty
and misery and all that the other person
went to Eaton and had every possible
advantage and they both finish up doing
the same crime well of course we think
that the guy who went to Eaton should
get a worth of more punishment but is
that ultimately Justified whatever
happened to him made him the kind of
person who's doing this right I I don't
think it is so so let's go back to
Hitler for a minute I know that in
especially in philosophical discussions
there is now a uh in recent years
somebody has proposed that we have a new
informal fallacy the reduction redactio
ethereum you know whatever you bring up
Hitler that's it that's the end of the
discussion but in fact I think there's a
good point it's the end no
I think it's a good point so my story
about Hitler is the following that there
is a cullingham line Owen Flanagan who
is a practicing Buddhist and a
philosopher and early on in his practice
he had the fortune to meet the Dalai
Lama and he was really bothered uh Owen
was really bothered by the Buddhist
notion that you should never be angry
because anger is is a disruptive
destructive emotion which I share as as
you know I tend to be also a story
practitioner and the stocks have the
same idea but Owen was like what do you
mean I shouldn't be angry and so his
example was if I had the Classic Time
Machine shouldn't I go back and in time
and kill hither before he does what he
what he's going to do and shouldn't I do
it because I'm angry at what he was
going to do and the Dalai Lama's
response was perfect in my opinion he
said yes you should absolutely go back
and kill hitron in fact you should do
with some fun fair if possible you
should make a big deal out of it you
know invite people to the party because
it's a big deal but no you should not be
angry because Hitler is just one more
point in the in the cosmic uh sequence
in the cosmic web of cause and effect it
did not ask to be there it was not
ultimately responsible for being there
he's just you should treat him as a
doctor treats a tumor you don't get
angry with tumors you just excise them
and if it's a big tumor you make a big
deal out of it you give a party
afterwards but other than that that so
that's the way I would approach things
now if you don't excite there's no more
because you don't want to you know take
it completely out then you try to reform
the term you try to bring it back to
some kind of normal so so should we put
away people if they're dangerous
actively dangerous to others yes I think
we should but what we should do during
that period is try to reform them if
possible at all uh that should not be a
punishment because the concept of
punishment makes no sense to me and I
just want to ask you one question that I
know Galen wants to come in are you
saying then that so in this sequence of
cause and effect is there no original
cause in your kind of philosophical no
no it says there's no first mover in
this there's no originating because the
cause and effect is a kind of cause and
effect without an original question the
quantum similarity the quantum
singularity at the big Bank pass
possibly
um but the question what the issue is
doesn't matter right whatever was at the
beginning uh the first mover of whatever
kind the fact is is we find ourselves in
a mechanical universe that works in a
certain way and we should act
accordingly not not by going after
fantasies like hell and heaven and stuff
like that by the way we always talk
about punishment but reward is the same
thing
we shouldn't be going around rewarding
people no rewards okay
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas